welcome to this video and I'm having
black as I usually do against a cowboy
in the house against he three always
plays a line that I have no idea about
let's try something else think he plays
no I thought he plays the advanced
variation and I wanted to try something
in the advanced variation I didn't
really do that he plays this line hmm ok
i'm playing something super solid him ok
what can play Queen d2 now ok doesn't
tween the two form for a very solid play
not sure about the timing here maybe I
start with this not question yeah this
is a bit stodgy oh it goes h4 it's very
that's very boring usually why should
try to keep his default option open I
really don't think at this sir this is
any any big issue for black
okay so how do I actually challenged the
night down by mp6 somewhat somehow why
do I go 85 at some point 5 p-5 I can try
this like be five or so yeah maybe maybe
try that b5 deform probably i'm no i'm
not really ambitious here but i'm
thinking about something active maybe
this is the wrong idea altogether after
this kind of stodgy opening okay here we
go i'm thinking about before him 1185
let's go here is it going before then
yeah maybe maybe he is so going before
hmm doesn't seem like a big deal but
might be okay maybe just do this see if
i can trade trade that night what i
wanted to do the whole time night over
and DA to c 6 wide really should not win
due to the bishop alone down okay that's
usually not enough
it's not very attractive of course I
mean understand but it should not lose
its the point okay so am I just staying
here in this position probably something
like this
so if it takes on hmm yeah okay well
before him before might be an idea
anyway anyway and this is what I wanted
to do in the first place so let's do it
so okay for now okay for maybe bishops
it too I can also take them for Bishop
takes now thats it shouldn't be so bad
and now should be five no that's not
leading to much of course i can go
looking for him just pinning actually
this is actually nice i look to you
three i can take with the ca Drock rook
takes Bishop b5 and then I will win day
three Pawn how does he prevent it yeah
he couldn't really and okay he could
play what he did play but there wasn't
really anything anything good to avoid
that I can go Bishop b5 now I think not
sure that I have to maybe I have other
ideas rook c8 to be too is there or is
this kind of a bad idea trying to
activate the look and let's do this my
time it I've ever really completely
ignored the time situation
huh that's not good
we should see two was something i don't
know i think the position is ok for me
anyway here but i'm down to one minute
it's not so great time working
maybe a four as a move trying to I'm
trying to trap this a little bit he
didn't do that should be five mini I
don't know why it's got to check them
again the time the time the time
position is cool I made cool it's okay
Luke will come to deform it's certainly
hope so d 1 equal
draw offered
yeah it's not much going on I'm just
just okay yeah but again you cannot
invade hear anything then I'm invading
myself check yeah this is it sir we know
the story here nothing is going on here
but I have no time on the clock check
lacking I can play that till hell
freezes over it's just to draw all the
way I don't know where did I spend that
much time I think at times it was just
for the whole game but somehow somehow I
can of around here it was really
completely useless to spend so much time
on some of those moves the thing is I
was starting to get it to get ambitious
here trying trying things and so on like
being active when I can just play any
movement and be okay that's not very
practical
now it's really nothing going on I mean
nothing maybe he had the odd chance here
when I was down to 16 seconds yeah I
think at one point he might have had
some kind of breakthrough but here like
a five I thought maybe but i can go King
g5 him so that is just wrong the whole
game as a drone to the to the very end
of course yeah this is some this is none
increment chess if you if you really
sometimes just fall asleep during during
the game like i did this line is it's
not very active but it's very difficult
to break down in fact i think that g3 h4
is just a strategic mistake after that
white is basically giving up any hope of
doing anything if white wants to do
something in his endgame es tu has to
get in something with G 4-h for trying
or f5 at some point difficult to do
anyway but this is this is just nothing
yam and you can it was pretty much shown
in the game yeah what can give them any
any hopes or something in this kind of
structure here just just about
completely equal maybe I could have done
something much easier that makes makes
my life a little bit simple i dunno yeah
i was i was thinking about playing for
an advantage here and I mean I saw that
this is for example very simple but I
wanted to try something but this is as
usual the wrong way to do it who's this
is of course a dead draw as I saw that
you can do this I can just I can just
stay here hmm now anyway you just have
to watch the clock thanks for watching